I listen to what my religion told me I
listen to what my culture told me but
there's some missing data I felt that
there was just some information that was
missing self-love is not an indulgence
it's not a nice-to-have it is a
prerequisite even if all you want to do
is feel successful you know we all talk
about business all the time but the
aspect of health is the most important
part nobody talks about it yeah what's
that belief nation at seven my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out onto
the world now I started to believe life
series to try to tackle topics outside
of just growing your business and so to
help you build your best believe life
today we're gonna look at eight things
that you need to know before you turn 30
enjoy
[Music]
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one life is not about you
with Neale Donald Walsch for the first
50 years of my life issue I thought that
my life was about me I had the attitude
of a 10 year old or a 9 year old or a 6
year old but I had that attitude when I
was 29 or 39 I just you know I thought
that wasn't a bad person I'm not trying
to paint myself as his horrible
individual but I was fairly
self-centered I was looking at my own
career my own goals my old objectives my
old needs my own wants my old desires I
tried to be even-handed about it if
somebody helped me and I tried to give
back if I could and all those things
that were taught to do but basically my
life was focused on me
fascinatingly even though my life was
focused on me virtually all the time my
life wasn't working I mean at some point
in my life I really got oh gosh I can't
seem to find happiness that lasts more
than a little while like I can't seem to
find success that lasts was it a little
while everything is so ephemeral it just
comes in and goes out comes in and goes
out I never seem to get anywhere to the
top of the mountain when when is to
struggle over this what I was
experiencing when I had my first
conversation with God so that's the
context that's the background why I was
given that wisdom because I asked God
okay obviously there's something here I
don't understand I listen to what my
daddy told me and listen to what my
mommy told me I listen to what my
religion told me I listen to what my
culture told me but there's some missing
data I felt that there was just some
information that was missing so I said
to God what is it what is it that I
don't understand here the understanding
of which would change everything God
said to be Neal it's really very simple
and then she said what you just said
here Neal your life is not about you
your life is about everyone else whose
life you touch and the way in which you
touch it and I said look I don't
understand it was supposed to give up
everything that I ever wanted her
desired her hoped for give up all of my
goals all of my objectives and she said
no no no I didn't say that I didn't say
that you don't have to set aside all of
your goals set aside all of your
objectives set aside all of the things
to do all of your desires no I didn't
say that but it's about achieving them
working toward them moving toward them
in a whole different way for a whole
different reason if you're doing those
things to enrich the lives of everyone
whose life you touch watch the world
fall in on you with Wonder and joy and
celebration but if you're doing those
things together to gather gather gather
get can't can't have more have more have
more but you just like you know you just
want to get as much as you can for
yourself if that's your prime motivation
you're gonna be struggling every day for
the rest of your life
rule number two credit cards are
dangerous with Mark Cuban don't use
credit cards of all the investments
you'll ever make
pain pain 19% or you know where 18% on
something is easily as easily the
dumbest that's money that you should be
keeping you can be saving it's a
different world now because you can be a
smart consumer you know you you have the
ability to price check anything on
Amazon or Walmart calm and you know what
you need to say for put it on layaway
with them now and ended up I had so many
credit cards cut up I actually I was
cleaning up some stuff and saw my old
credit report Sears Amex Visa Kaufman's
he's old I mean the situation I was in
was like anybody who would give me a
credit card I would use because I didn't
have any money so I needed to use it and
so I literally there someone's flipping
the old chunks of my old credit card
somewhere so you know stay away from
credit rule number three practice
self-love with Tim Ferriss I realized
I'd say two years ago but especially
less six months very recent that
and this is the part that would make my
Tim of five years ago just Crane like
vomit a little in his own mouth much it
is I'm not gonna mince words I still
have trouble sayings like self-love is
not an indulgence it's not a
nice-to-have it is a prerequisite even
if all you want to do is feel successful
and take care of the people you love the
most to really take care of them you
have to as I've heard said put on your
oxygen mask first and if you don't do
that like you you are also shortchanging
your ability to care for other people
completely and that that's been a very
very much an hundred eighty degree
about-face for me right because for a
long time I was like I don't need to
care for myself mmm like that's the word
keeps coming back to me which is
self-indulgent like this is
self-indulgent mink who cares rule
number four learn to say no with Robin
Sharma what makes a great company is
less about your good opportunities and a
lot more about you having the bravery
and discipline to say no to you to your
many good opportunities what destroys a
great company is actually opportunity
bloating too many good opportunities so
literally you diffuse your team's
bandwidth and you get distracted and you
see with so many companies right now
they they sort of found their sweet
pocket and they were absolutely winning
in their marketplace and they decided to
go hmm we've got this app that is really
changing the game and owning the
marketplace let's get into food delivery
let's get into this let's get into that
it happened to General Electric as well
and you probably know they decided at
one point if we can't be one or two in
any market we're going
get out of that market that's the key
point I'm trying to make no you're
mighty mission no your monomaniacal
focus and then have the discipline to
say no to everything else so you can
lock and load on your finest opportunity
to completely change the game rule
number five have a healthy lifestyle
with Daymond John you know we all talk
about business all the time but the
aspect of Health is the most important
part nobody talks about it yeah nobody
talks about it most business men and
women you go around and you're traveling
all the time you know you know the best
things then you're you're a two and
three dinners a night
you're drinking because you born with a
lot of people you're drink cause you're
happy because you're off you know you're
not sleeping you're in between climates
and things of that nature and then all
of a sudden it implodes and you have
nothing left
yeah crazy yeah do you have a schedule
every day then for your health or now
mmm I try and you know I'm not perfect I
go back to the book walk then to look at
all the things that I want to do so you
know I'll give you example suede you
know loves to say hey I get up and I
bust down you know four sets of 25
push-ups a day and gets my adrenaline
running I was doing that until I blew my
shoulder out there and something else
right yeah so now what I do I sure do i
I was actually diving in Mexico and
trying to embarrass my daughters what
this was this dive and I hurt my
shoulder I prized myself but but yeah
but you know all right so now I have to
adjust that so what do I do sit up all
right so maybe now after I will answer
emails after uh when I do but I'll be
walking on the treadmill for two hour
answering them you know later on so I
get I get my put the steps and I'll do
leg lifts I'll do whatever the case is
but again it's always adjusting right
I'm not gonna make any suit oh my heart
blown out and I can't do anything right
there's a cow Manor climb Mount
Kilimanjaro you know I was so late well
what the hell's wrong with me I got
something on my shoulder here and I
can't work out rule number six save
money with Tony Robbins we're not saving
for the reason that I think majority of
us have this thought process it's part
of human nature that today is more
important than tomorrow today's right
here and I actually interviewed a group
behavioural economists these are people
that spend their whole life trying to
figure out why does human nature screw
us up around money and how do we trick
ourselves to do the right things and one
of them came up with a brilliant system
so if you said I can't save anything
this is what I do with those people I
said look let's say you save 10 percent
ok let's save at least 5 percent even
three and a half percent you're not
gonna see it gone if you just make it
automatic but I said here's the real
secret what this man did is he said
everybody can diet tomorrow everything
you can save money tomorrow and he
created the system called save money for
tomorrow so you save a little bit today
and you go to your employer and there's
a way to do this automate it in your
401k and you say you know what every
time I get a raise I went three and a
half percent of my money to go straight
into this account I'll never see it so
if you had a 10% raise you get 6 and 1/2
today and the other three now if you
wouldn't see but it go on your account
well when they do this over a 10-year
period of time in the Midwest
blue-collar workers not a lot of income
they found themselves within 10 years
saving 14% on average and 65% of them
are saving 19% remember 20% is what made
that guy wealthy at the level of 70
million dollars so there's ways to trick
yourself to do this and if you do it I'm
telling you the most important decision
you're gonna make
is the decision you make to automate
some savings rule number seven read more
with Warren Buffett I should mention one
thing about reading it was at the
library here at Columbia I wish I spent
probably more time than any other soon I
lived there particle II but and I pulled
the book out there happen to be whose in
America and it told me something about
my professor Benjamin where I am and
then I looked up and I went to the
library and I said I want to learn more
about this because I learned this over
here that changed my whole life
you know we own Geico now because of
that library and directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that it's the chance I
I read about one-fifth the pace the bill
does but I still spend five or six hours
a day greeting I mean it just you can
learn so much I love biography just
to be able to live the lives of these
people have been extorted seeing so
extraordinary the lessons and the you
know the discouragements they face just
everything about it so I did you can't
get enough of reading had done and rule
number eight the last one before a very
special bonus clip is travel more with
the vagabrothers well there's only so
much you can learn from books travel
teaches from experience and experience
is the best teacher of all what better
way to learn about history than hiking
up Machu Picchu exploring angkor wat at
dawn or wandering ancient roman ruins
that's what makes travel so valuable
because it opens your mind and broadens
your perspectives and as cliche as it
sounds
Travel can help you find yourself
sometimes we don't know who we are and
what we want to do can we step away from
family and friends and tune into our
inner voice after college I traveled
through Southeast Asia on the blogging
and storytelling which eventually led me
to team up with my brother to found this
channel
that's because travel gives you the
space to just be you in a way that you
could never do back home
now I've got a very special bonus clip
with Jordan B Peterson on how to have
good friends but before that I want to
know what did you learn from this video
which one resonated the most with you
that you need to maybe reflect on and
apply to your life and that I maybe miss
I 9 or 10 that you want to add to the
list leave it down in the comments below
I'm really curious to see what you have
to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
with you can't want to see you do well
yes exactly
yeah yeah make friends with people who
want the best for you right yeah it's so
well then it's a really it's a real
technical idea so Carl Rogers who's a
psychotherapist great psychotherapist
I'd very much recommend his books to
people especially if they want to learn
to listen because he was really good at
teaching people how to listen he had
this idea that what he would manifest
towards his clients in therapy was
unconditional positive regard and I've
always had trouble with that because
well because you don't treat your
children for example with unconditional
positive reviews no matter what someone
says you're saying yeah that's a good
idea well that's that's why it's tricky
well what do you what do you he didn't
articulate it I think as well as he
might have what you want to do is for
your child is that you want the best for
the best in them that's what you want
and that's what you want from people
that you surround yourself with
now they'll hold you to our eyes
standard if that's the case right
because whenever you degenerate in any
of the multiple ways that you're likely
to degenerate they're gonna like whack
you on the back of the head and say you
know clue the hell in you know you're
you're demeaning yourself you're less
than you could be and there's real
judgment and then it's harsh you know
but with friends it's the same thing you
want friends they're not friends if
they're not these people you want
friends who when something good happens
to you they're at that's good for you
right they're happy about that they're
not like all bitter and resentful
underground and like saying horrible
things behind your back and telling you
how they did something that was better
and trying to drag you down it's like
that's not helpful and then when
something bad happens to you and you go
to them and you say look this terrible
thing happened to me first of all they
don't try to top it with some like
horrible thing that happened to them
because they don't have the patience to
listen and second they're not secretly
gloating about the fact that catastrophe
finally befell you it's like they're
actually hurt by it and that chapters an
injunction is like take a look at the
people that are around you and if
they're not on the side of what's good
for you then walk away because well
first of all that's best for them too if
you put up with
all you're doing is enabling it it's
like well it's okay that you mistreat me
in a way that's harmful to me and
everyone else it's like actually no that
is not okay it's not in it's not the
least bit okay that doesn't mean you
shouldn't try to help someone when
they're down that's a whole different
issue raise your standard Apple at the
core it's core value is that that people
need passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top 10 most of success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details